if you're really serious about your
political views which i like to think we
are you want to win people over and you
want to win the argument you don't just
want to keep chatting let's just chat
with people for ever and ever and let's
just you know throw around and if you
want to win the argument hello and
welcome to trigonometry I'm Frances
Foster I'm Constance in kitchen and our
very special interview this week is with
two returning guests of trigonometry
Claire Fox and Ella Whelan welcome back
[Music]
for anyone who doesn't know who you are
Claire you are of course the founder and
director of the academy of ideas and
very recently bricks a party MEP for the
Northwest have I got that right no and
you're a brilliant journalist and you're
part of the battle of ideas which is one
of the things that we'll be talking
about and an author of course in your
own right so welcome back both of you
it's gonna be after that very long intro
we wanted to talk to you about the
battle of ideas the event but actually
the battle of ideas as the battle of
ideas more generally about what's
happening in our society what's
happening about just our ability to have
a conversation we've had you know the
the discussion and Parliament in the
last couple of weeks about inflammatory
language with all this stuff is kicking
off and it seems to be very difficult
now to discuss any ideas at all without
people getting aggravated and insults
being thrown so where are we in terms of
our ability to talk about things as a
society in your opinion Claire I think
you feel as though societies become
tongue-tied in some respects there's a
real sense in which people are very
conscious if they say the wrong thing
they might be attacked for being
offensive for being inflammatory for
saying things which will upset at the
people being accused of inciting
violence so there's a sense of people
walking on eggshells that coexists with
people being entirely unrestrained and
saying the most preposterous I don't
know whether I can say that and then
people just being utterly abusive in a
way you know and by the way I
think that this is almost regardless of
what kind of politics you espouse it's
not particularly confined to one group
of people I think the recent
parliamentary spat about inflammatory
language caused some upsets because and
as you've rightly pointed out one would
never be able to use a metaphor anymore
if you constantly having zip people say
you can't use any battle analogies or
any military analogies well we're in
trouble because we run a festival called
the Battle of ideas for education and so
on so you know that's what that's where
we start but on the other hand it also
felt very hypocritical because it might
well be that Boris Johnson the Prime
Minister had ratcheted up the language
in certain he was doing very big
rhetorical and Confused sways of making
himself out to be the great leader of
this big a brexit battle and people were
saying well you know calm down a bit but
these on the one hand are people who've
spent quite some time accusing other
people have been Nazis fascists you know
leading to the Third Reich and so on and
so forth and quite violent imagery has
been deployed in terms of trying to stop
and brexit now they want to just get
confined to brexit I'm just saying that
the sense of double standards in
hypocrisy is something that we have to
bear in mind just wines people up but
certainly winds me up well I mean we're
all according to some people all Nazis
in this room meeting surely Elly isn't
that people's right to you know say what
they think you know if someone thinks
you're a fascist welcome to do that and
it doesn't really have any effect no it
doesn't have any effect if you it only
does if you let it have an effect and
obviously and I unclear and the actually
the slogan of the back of ideas is free
speech allowance it's very much about
having that public debate being in favor
of people just saying what they think
but I think the context is key because
at the moment the panic about speech and
words like surrender or humbug or
whatever is that politicians are very
terrible
as well as the kind of worry about
escalating language on social media and
the fact it has sometimes quite serious
issues about as class as abusive lunch
on social media is happening at a time
in which we've got a broad political
issue going on which is a quite deep
fear of the public and a fear of the
masses and quite a lot of prejudice
going on and so there's this sort of
when people especially people in
political power and talk about the the
fear of demagogues or Nazis or whoever
is inciting violence through their
speech and the needs kind of everyone to
calm down what it really is is saying is
we've quite scared of having a public
debate because if that public debate
happens then you know the mob are going
to grab their pitchforks and are going
to come after us and of course that's
one entirely not true but it also is
it's escalating and creating a problem
that they're afraid of they're afraid
that people are going to get violent get
rebellious and cause problems at the
same time they're saying no one talked
about anything
no one criticized us no one do anything
anything you say is not just wrong but
illegal and I'll tell you there's one
this is what people who are interested
in free speech always point out and it's
true that if you want to make a problem
out of something push it underground
censor it give it a kind of glamour that
it shouldn't necessarily enjoy and
that's one problem happens so the
antidote is always sunlight is always
more debate as always more speech and
you've got at the moment a political
establishment which is just so hostile
to any kind of discussion about its
actions which I think isn't going to end
well if it keeps going down this very
censorious route and this is where the
battle of ideas the festival that you
guys run every year comes in because one
of the great things about that is you
genuinely get people from all over the
political spectrum I mean you know we'll
be interviewing Lord of Darkness who is
not going to be that popular with most
of us Pro brakes of view as I imagine
but but you get people from across the
spectrum genuinely and that's one of the
things I really enjoyed but I'm curious
how you managed to do that actually
because we struggle to get like you know
kind of woke leftist guests on because
they are afraid to be
and tarnished by association so how do
you get all these people together well I
mean I think people understand that I
think people are cautious about things
being a setup and so a lot of the time
in political debate in the media for
example anyone who's ever done it knows
that you get put into a room and you get
told to kind of battle it out with each
other
it can often be quite fractious the
difference about the festival is because
it's centered around public debate
actually the focus is not on the
speaker's themselves but within their
interaction with a wider audience and so
people understand that this is a genuine
platform where you will be given a fair
shot to try and win over the audience
and I think anyone who's serious about
their political views whether you are a
socialist or a hard right person
whatever view you have what we're
essentially saying is go for it and you
might well completely win over the
audience and I might be devastated
because I've lost the argument but it's
a it is a fair game and it has been a
fair game for 15 years and I think
people really appreciate that space to
do it and as it happens as often is the
case that at the festival and I will
enter a room hating someone's political
views and ready to make contrary to the
floor and really nail them and come out
being convinced that actually I was
being completely one-sided about
something so it's it's that kind of a
it's a different space for public debate
then happens within you know media
discussions or other places yeah I mean
a couple of things to add and I think
that to go back to our prior
conversation in terms of why people
maybe would be reluctant to come on your
show or sometimes we were locked in
speak our festival like the Battle of
ideas I think that one of the more
worrying aspects of what's happened in
recent years and this is relatively new
is that labels have been used to dealer
Jetta my's different opponents so they
and basically if you know if you are a
kind of far-right fascist maybe I mean
like the way the four of us you know and
you want to go no actually I'm on the
left and I'm just kind of a leak a
reasonable Democrat but you kind of
can't get the wording your dealer just
about because what that says is you
aren't worth engaging with so that's one
thing
you don't have to talk to you at all
because you know if you're so beyond the
pale why would you bother the second
thing that happens of course is that
there's guilt by association so we would
sort of go well actually I I really like
what sug anomaly doing what the battle
of mind is doing but I don't want my
mates to then say that I might agree
with the people who organized it but
we've always had the approach and in
turn supporting on the festival that
pretended that we haven't got opinions I
mean I'm you know well-known commentator
I am now temporarily an MEP hopefully
very temporary one of the co conveners
of the festival this year and I'm not
we're well known for having opinions but
that doesn't mean that you don't run a a
panel that's fair you have different
opinions and I think the key to the
success of the festival is we trust the
audience and when we first organized
this festival and they we said half the
time is given over to the public
audience it's quite a lot of people who
would be speakers said oh you mean it's
open to anyone what do you what do you
do if there's trouble I think go anyway
yeah so there's this assumption that if
you let the public in to have their say
I think they're gonna all stand up would
be completely vile well that there's
going to be a fight anyway I think we've
had one or two incidents over the year
one mentally ill person one person drunk
at 11 o'clock on a Sunday morning that's
it then we have thousands of people
every year and of that then we've got a
USP which is speakers will say at the
end of being on a panel oh my god why
did you get the audience from because
they were all really smart asking
interesting questions but they're also
you've got levers you've got remainders
you've got woke students you've got free
speech absolutist and they're all seem
to be able to engage with each other
well shocker for the lock I mean the for
us that is what public debate is not
just what we should be it is what it is
if you trust the speakers and the
audience or interact with each other
intelligently and it creates a really
open space it's a great point in
remember when I went last year I just
found it in
invigorating the way people were
speaking and they were listening and we
were talking about this before you
listen to news night all your question
tom and it just degenerates into this
route how much responsibility to the
mainstream media have for in a sense the
basing public debate
well I always looked into kind of blame
the media yeah because they're an easy
target yeah I am one of the people who
sits on the couch and shouts at the
media so it's not as though I don't but
I think that and the media have in
recent years on certain subjects become
slightly compromised in terms of the
impartiality question and and I do worry
about that because I think it's going to
lead to a backlash of people just saying
I'm not going to take any notice of the
mainstream media I'm delighted that
there are alternative forms of media
such as trigonometry I mean that makes
me that that kind of widening out of the
discussion in the debate is hugely
important and I hate that that actually
keeps the mentioning media is slightly
more honest because they actually have
to look and say wow a lot of people are
watching these guys doing their
interviews I mean maybe we got to look
up why there's less people watching our
current affairs no no no please stop
doing unique thank you very much what I
was going to say with that was that
element that rightly made the point
about the setup I mean the number of
times that I've been invited onto the
media where it's basically we've got
three reasonable people and the mad
lunatic Claire Fox come to join us as
well and they don't exactly introduce
you like that but you're basically there
we have to have balance that we've
invited the lunatic on yes you've got
mad extremist views and you are walking
into this situation where you're being
set up with a certain sneer and I always
try and be reasonable at all times so
that and then you connect tonight oh you
seem to not be what we thought you would
be but I think that from an audience's
point of view politics not the media but
politics has squeezed out voters
citizens and the electorate from the
debate we had a brief flowering of their
emergence around a particular referendum
where they felt that they were back
being taken seriously and since then
they've been denounced and we're told
not certain seriously which is one of
the explanations I think for why people
are so completely over the top on social
media because what you get is they're so
frustrated that they're being talked
about and down to but without any way of
expressing themselves that now that you
have got Twitter and Facebook you feel
like alright and you know and they're
shouting from the couch takes the form
of shouting on Twitter and in a way
letting off steam so you can understand
the frustration of that being ignored
and patronized and talked about now
express itself so I don't I'm not as
frightened by social media abuse as some
people make out because I just think in
a ways people just rightly expressing
that awesome frustration even though a
lot of it's aimed at me and a lot of it
smile well first I'm anything there's
two things to say about the mainstream
media honest like not too much give me a
lot of work but on the other hand I
think part of the problem is the
influence of social media there's one
specific influence of social media in
that lots of the television programs
radio programs are seeking to get gotcha
moments to be clipped on Twitter I mean
that's just like their modus operandi
now and pin the politician get them to
say the bad thing put it on Twitter well
that means that you often spend five
minutes listening to an incredibly dull
conversation on The Today program or on
Newsnight or on channel 4 wherever it is
where you're just waiting for the gotcha
moment and often doesn't happen so like
there's countless time to I've sat
listening to the morning radio hearing
someone ask a politician the same
question you know I'm not going to get
the answer out there it's like a poor
man's Paxman and it just doesn't work
and it's really really boring and it is
really frustrating because then you do
end up wanting to go on Twitter and
saying what [ __ ] hell are you doing
won't talk about the news and the other
side of it is that I have had countless
experiences in green rooms and back
rooms before and after shows where
people kind of forget that you are not
part of the mix of things you're not
part of the media establishment so they
start talking about politics and what's
really interesting they often talk about
how
silly boring of god we have to talk
about Briggs again oh god we have to
talk about this again and what they
don't realize is that for many people
only van remain side this is actually a
very exciting moment in projects because
things seem to be up in the air and if
you had a sensible sense of the news
producers being able to galvanize on
that you could do something really
interesting with this you could actually
really engage an audience you could
actually you know you've got a political
space in which people want to talk about
things so use that but I think they're
still stuck in this notion of what they
want is just that a current political
mass to go away so they can get back to
doing you know the kind of things that
you saw in the thick of it you know
launching a policy talking about it
doing all these sort of mundane things
they want to go back to business as
usual that's politicians and the media
establishment you just don't want to
deal with the current fray and that's
coming across as either very dull or
very febrile exchanges and I don't think
any of us come out any better off from
either watching or being part of it if
there's one of the things when we
started the festival and before it was
fashionable we always used to say about
the Battle of ideas you know get out of
your echo chamber I mean now that's a
cliche but at the time it was quite an
important declaration as far as we were
concerned that you should come in here
are their opinions beyond your own but I
think that what's now incredible is that
when people actually do have civilized
exchanges over even very febrile issues
like brexit that people actually don't
want that to occur so for example UK and
exchanging Europe and you were actually
involved in the festival this year who
academics who are you know broadly
speaking based on the research not that
keen that we leave the European Union
and I don't agree there's the number of
the the statements that they come out
but they're actually really interesting
I read their publications I'm interested
you know and this works both ways but
they did a podcast with me and they got
abused for interviewing me by their own
followers why is that woman on and I and
I also did my first and MEP and blog for
them with as they asked me to and again
I got they got a lot of abuse for
allowing me a platform and by the way
just to show I'm being fair minded about
it it was also the case that when I've
retweeted and said it's worth reading
this from you kind of changing Europe
and on and on and what's the problems
with No Deal brexit and some of the real
challenges of it people who are my
supporters will say why you retweeting
9jo and I'm like because I think
everyone should read it's very wrong we
should argue against it so I think that
the media the mainstream media sadly are
far too prepared to put the label on you
you're there to perform it in a role and
if you don't kind of Jean it's like that
kind of what was that good we need to go
fight fight you know but it was like
that sort of right if you don't perform
there's some sort of like fighting you
know horrible kind of like spitting it
to each other which actually often
spontaneously happens but if you don't
because you think that's a reasonable
point I think this they're almost
disappointed that you're not giving them
the gotcha moment or the kind of clip
that you can then say this is real live
politics well actually it's not no it's
not as a [ __ ] unpleasant exchange why
don't we actually have an attempt at
understanding each other's perspectives
well just to show that we're fair minded
whenever we talk about the mainstream
media one thing that should be mentioned
actually a lot of people on our side in
terms of new media are doing the same
thing as well there's lots of people who
are not being fair or reasonable
objective in any way that's just a long
way of constantine saying he wants to go
back on good morning Britain
that's mainstream media and one of the
things they do is they they very they're
very careful to make sure as you'll know
to make sure that you know you kept in a
separate room from the other guests who
you're supposedly debating it was quite
funny I was on a radio program the other
day and a woman who didn't know me I was
chatting to her she didn't know who it
was and she was saying oh yeah you know
good morning Britain when you know that
that kind of debate where they have
someone who's black talking about racism
and then they get a racist on against
them and I was like well I'm usually the
racist well you are but one of my
favorite moments the battle of ideas
last year actually becoming to talk
about identity politics like it was you
were hosting and moderating a debate
between a bunch of people and you were
taking questions from the audience and
yeah I think you took questions from two
men in a row and then at this point a
woman stood up at the back and started
shouting about how you need to ask a
question you get a question from a woman
and you went that's not how we do things
here just sit down and shut up I'll ask
and I thought it was quite refreshing to
see that you know that this idea of
identity politics doesn't seem to be
quite as strong in that space as it is
elsewhere is that is that fair to say
well we we challenged the presumptions
that are basically a kind of box-ticking
ritual and I remember that incident
because the truth was it was the first
round of questions for people put their
hands up who were men and I was taking
the third one when the interjection
happened but we'd only just started the
discussion so I was hardly cutting out
every woman in the room and there was
hundreds of people at that event and
that particular conversation and you
know as one would anticipate cause a lot
of women in the audience eventually
spoke but it wasn't because somebody had
said are there any women in you know we
got any blacks
the whole thing is yeah you see an
audience you're trying to encourage an
open debate you're not sitting there
going have we had enough LGBTQ I
speakers to satisfy the quota police no
that's not the way it is but
interestingly we don't play the identity
politics game at the battle ideas but if
you actually look at the audience you
will find that they are all ages all
ethnicities yes no doubt will sexuality
they are basically they are the public
yes we are a mixed in very crowd yes but
we're not trying to get in a group of
people it's also the case that I always
think as we always do which is and in
one of the debates that I was doing on a
few years ago you know somebody sort of
said well you know I just feel as though
you know this is completely biased and
what about the woman's voice and it was
interesting because most of the people
who'd spoken had been women but what
they meant was it's not what I want you
know it it's not to be an accusation
that you were bringing too many mint men
in because the women who'd spoken
actually were not arguing what this
young feminists had wanted them to argue
and I said well it doesn't really matter
what gender you are just speak stop
trying to do that right say what you
want and then we'll have the argument so
I hope that by the end of it people
realize actually it's better to not do
the box-ticking cuz you get more
interesting discussion and also I think
it's I mean last year we ran a strand
that I chaired on feminism and out of
five or six debates however many it was
there was only one guy on the panel and
it didn't really come into my mind but
just so happened that on issues of
discussions about gender pay gap I
decided to get four people who are very
good and that they all happen to be
women and inevitably at least once every
time in the debate someone got up and
said well where's the representation of
men well it's not an you think it's just
this has just gone too far this is just
that's that's funny like that someone's
decided to take issue with that but I
think a lot of the time most people do
think that's a bit ridiculous and they
do if they come along to the debate and
they hear that for me always the most
crucial thing is have you got the
political balance right
and in some cases having the political
balance right with the best people that
you can get the most interesting people
you can get they might all look the same
they might all come from the same
background but the question is are they
going to say different things and I
think people might sometimes people
might join our audiences and be kind of
sitting a bit like already have a
prejudice about what's going to happen
but then they hear people open their
mouths and speak and your mind changes
and you think okay actually that person
is completely on my side or completely
not on my side I think the thing about
the identity politics wars we've got a
strand on it and this year talking about
everything from in cells and Peterson
and toxic masculinity and all that kind
of discussion up to gross-out feminism
which is like about the person is
political and everything in between race
and all sorts I think that people are at
this point so sick of the identity
politics was because it's so unpleasant
I mean because you there really is no
end to it it doesn't matter if you are a
you know a woman of color who's also a
lesbian someone will always trump you
that's the kind of like identity
politics Olympics going on and so you
can't ever really feel safe you can't
ever really feel solid in your position
if you're going to engage in that debate
because someone will always come along
and be more victimized more have an
identity that's more important in the
hierarchy than you and so I like to
think that a lot of people who come to
the festival want to just put that aside
and then talk about the real politics
behind it because yeah definitely even
as someone who if you do buy into the
whole identity thing you know like if if
I if we ever go on panels and say well
as a woman you just know that it feels
hollow it does Bob I was gonna say was
that the the the reality is is that you
just get born you have a skin color
you're a woman I mean I know that saying
that I'm a woman is now become a matter
of major political controversy because I
probably be accused of some
discrimination but I mean in general
these are not achievements in one's life
yeah I'm happy become here you become
yes is not about those things but it's
about your mind about the new views you
have the morality that you embrace and
all of these things and part of growing
up of course is is is growing into
someone it's working out who you will be
in the in the scheme of things and I
think it's so vile that we've got to a
point where we're we're able to trump
each other based on something we didn't
achieve that's all I'm saying I mean if
somebody says well I'm black what it's
like yes but I mean what does that mean
it doesn't help me get anywhere in terms
of understanding the world we live in
but I think you're actually right the
people are feds with it that one of my
mates actually said to me a year or so
ago you know I've never felt so black
and I didn't understand what he meant
but what he was saying was that he now
feels as that I mean he's been involved
in anti-racist politics and politics and
in general for a long time but what he
was saying was he now feels as though
the only way that people see him is as
black right and then rather than been
changed seriously as an intellectual a
film critic and all of these things
he's now sort of invited onto panels
because he's black
you know he's ashamed to have an insight
because he's like where is he you saying
no like that's not what I want to be
defined by so it's ironic that having
allowed racism to define people through
skin colour for many years and that's
you know still what a racist does is
assumes your character and your morality
in your whole being because of your skin
color or whichever particular prejudice
you go down now it's identity politics
that does the same and I think that
people have a sneaky feeling that this
is very very very regressive and so at
least I think there's a sense of relief
when they come to the bathroom ideas
that we don't just accommodate to that I
was slightly rude with that woman as we
often do is to say things like you know
if you find something offensive argue
back don't walk out and storm out or you
know that say you're triggered and not
it but dissipate you know don't complain
about those things you know let's just
have a public conversation about really
important issues and trust each other
that we can cope with
the challenges or a friend that we might
hear in the course of that what do you
put heat sort of just to find very
unknown even been asked a question
equally though you don't exclude people
who are of that way of thinking they
were playing God there's like I mean
probably the majority of people there
believe that they cannot argue for that
they can argue against what I've just
said
but you argue against it not boycott yes
or label
explain why you think it different to do
that yeah yeah I mean it is it is
fortunately or unfortunately I've become
a serious political viewpoint in terms
of most of our political narrative today
is defined by identity politics even you
know something like brags it has been
largely attempted to be defined by
identity politics and so he's got to
engage with it even if you are like me
and Claire someone who's very skeptical
of the benefits of seeing things through
an identity politics lens you know it is
actually a lot more and more becoming
the established way of thinking which is
you know we've just been talking about
the mainstream media the way they cast
debates will be through an identity
politics lens the way they see having
topics will be around an identical it
expends so that's the realm were in we
are happy to take that on what we're not
happy to do is be counted by it so
that's what I think that the we a
caution to us all
I mean I'm a great fan of cet'aeni
McGrath or you know rather as the and
and I love that and you've done lots of
things on the issues of identity and had
some great guests on trigonometry
discussing this but I I do think that I
got to say to myself all the time you
know I don't want to over lampoon them
because the reason I mention to anyone
that this easy make fun of yeah because
the most ludicrous sides of these things
are let's be frank you know easy to
satirize and say for God's sake and it
can be like that but there are obviously
things that one needs to engage in and
although I hate the promiscuous use of
the word far-right or racist and so on
there are racists I encountered them and
there's quite a lot of people at the
moment and he were having a big campaign
against the brexit party on the basis
that it's too politically correct for
having allowed a commie at Pro migrant
like me in it
in its ranks and they are more than
willing to explain their views on
deportations and immigration and they
are openly racist right and and so I
don't want and you can see that people
when they're on the receiving end of
some pretty nasty attacks if you're a
woman or if you're black or what have
you you you you you look to different
political ways of organizing I don't
think that identity politics is the way
forward I think it's really regressive
but I don't want to suggest that there's
no issues in society that need to be
confronted and tackled and that's where
the interesting political argument comes
well I do you could tackle that then
should it be through and kind of saying
we as ethnic minorities want to organize
in this way or should it be more a
pronouncing racist company and so on and
so forth so we try and take these things
seriously rather than just dismissing
them all guys just to let you know my
show all well that ends well which I
advertised earlier the Bill Murray that
is now very close to selling out so
we've had to open up another day I will
be doing it again with Francis emceeing
again on the 24th of November the links
in the description I'm also coming to
Cambridge in in November as well so
check that out absolutely please come
down it's going to be a great show when
I'm on and then when Constantine zone
you just enjoy the interval there is no
interval by the way so it's just me and
Francis will see that we're talking
about identity politics identity
politics is something I mean it's been
embraced by the right but very much by
the left and labels and all the rest of
it and I see you too if I would give you
a label it'd be a homeless lefties in
that like me we are of the left but we
look at the left and we go ah for [ __ ]
sake and we just go I mean I can't vote
later in the next election I just can't
um did you tell us number one what being
left-wing means and is it compatible
with now being a Labour voter I don't
from my opinion anyway I don't think
being left-wing in the interests of
working-class liberation has ever been
compatible with the voting with the
Labour Party for a number of reasons
that are actually too long to go into in
this interview but the funny thing is I
think clay you've said this before as
well as that my views in terms of what I
want from society and societal change
haven't changed so that episode whether
they're left-wing or not or you know it
often feels quite lazy to call yourself
left-wing now it's just like saying I'm
a nice person because right-wing has
become evil but my views haven't changed
in terms of what I want to see in a
future Society but I think what has
changed is the the rest of the
conversation so people who now still
call themselves left-wing in that quite
lazy way are for example if we take a
figure like Paul Mason who is a lefty by
all accounts of he's understood to be
one but he's become this you know
incredible cheerleader for the European
Union to month to my mind is you know
the antithesis of all kind of left-wing
euro skepticism and laughing thought of
works liberation so these things have
been become completely confused and part
of the problem is that the left as a
kind of block have just moved towards a
sort of centrist establishment outlook
from my point of view so it's not about
you know challenging the nature of the
way societies organized and arguing for
more for everyone and you know let's
make massive societal change it's about
sort of tinkering at the edges
you know making working life slightly
nicer for people slightly raising the
minimum wage taxing rich people a little
bit more it's all this kind of stuff
that seems like really boring centrism
or kind of your socialism light and I
think what you have to assess if you are
someone like myself perhaps Claire who
you know still holds on to some of the
serious and concrete left-wing values
like freedom of speech like euro
scepticism at the moment and on other
things what is where is the debate today
and the debate I think rightly or
wrongly isn't anymore about left or
right it isn't about these clear
political distinctions because we're not
in the 1980s were not in the same world
as we were when class politics was a
very real thing so you it is just you
have to face up the fact that it is just
politically lazy and rather dishonest to
keep going on about we're the lefties
and you're the right wingers because the
vast majority of the population out
there just don't see things in that way
anymore
that might be a good thing that might be
a bad thing it might be changing as it
happens because as we've seen the kind
of discussion about breaks it has become
quite clearly cut between an us-and-them
narrative and who knows where that's
going to go but I don't think you can
anymore be safe in those right and left
labels because they've just been
hollowed out I mean I do feel
politically homeless and you can't say
that you own MEP for the breaks I mean a
party that was actually only formed
because there was a pre-existing
movement hmm I mean you know you can't
and no disrespect to the people who set
up the bracing party but they didn't go
out and build it from scratch because it
was already three years worth of people
wandering around saying I feel
politically homeless and I'm so
frustrated about than non-delivery of
the votes leave in the referendum that
then you kind of have a party that comes
along with the title of the brexit party
and sweeps up that constituency and so
therefore it's not the traditional
political party that we've known from
the past and its slogan change politics
for good has got a much greater
resonance than I thought it would
and because when I go and talk to people
people say yeah we need new political
movements new party you know they want a
kind of refreshing of politics because
they do feel politically homeless I mean
there was a very moving moment that I I
was at a meeting and one woman stood up
and said you know I've been in the
Conservative Party for twenty years and
until recently I had never met a trade
unionist ever and now I'm going to leave
meetings and I'm meeting you know
there's Communist Party members over
there there's members of the RMT there's
the Conservatives all sorts of people
here right so he was kind of honest and
then from the back of the room the next
contribution was somebody stood up and
said I'm a shop steward and I've
recently just got involved in the brexit
party as it happens in that instance and
I've always despised and hated every
single Tory and I found myself on a ball
with that very lady the other day and we
got on like a house on fire and so
people are realizing as well that maybe
the tribes from the past is slightly
different we've got new political
challenges yeah but the other thing I
would say was you know I was interviewed
by a number of publications last in the
last week or so Washington Post New
Yorker they all sort of start off and
they say well you've had a past you know
one minute you're the Revolutionary
Communist Party and the next minute
you're brexit party and I said there was
a 25 year gap because what's happened is
because I actually and it was unusual
when I stood up and said you know I
didn't think I was going to end up on
the same platform is Nigel fried when I
first was announced as a candidate you
know I come from the left I wasn't
expecting this to then mean that there
was a kind of wholesale going over
everything that was ever written by the
revolution college party that I was in
25 years ago and then trying to suggest
that I'd said it two seconds ago and I'm
not denouncing that past but there's a
lot of water gone under the bridge since
then in terms of politics I mean like I
I mean by that that it didn't used to be
that if you were a free speech
absolutist
that people would then say so you're far
right I mean the left embrace you know
actually still in America is the
cases that people on the Left are
associated with free speech I consider
this to be part of the Enlightenment
gain that you would have free speech and
open mind you know it
Ella's already mentioned you know that
the left has had the major with the
major figures in Euro skepticism and the
emergence of the EU
Toni ban I mean the one thing that I
agreed with Jeremy Corbyn for for 25
years was he's asked you to democracy in
relation to the imposition and
anti-democratic nature of the European
Union I mean it's not my fault he's
changed his mind or being cowardly away
he is the leader of a party who only
this morning I think one of his MPs I
think it's Angela regal and people I'm
pretty sure just said let's be frank and
tell everyone that brexit is an all
right far-right project right now that's
not even just saying it's a Tory project
right you know and then Jeremy Corbyn
says we don't want to bankers brexit I
think you know the bit where the bankers
burnt the bank the bank supported remain
I mean what are you talking about I mean
what does that mean even right they
funded a lot of remain companies opening
in the public sphere they've argued that
we should stay in there so I know that
what I'm trying to say is is that these
it does get to the point where the
labels become meaningless
I was the publisher of our magazine
which had previously been living Marxism
I was in the Revolutionary Communist
Party into my 30s before it closed
itself down and but I broadly of course
I think of myself as on the Left I've
had some sort of but the world around me
and what constitutes left-wing has
changed and when I see people who are
the leaders of left-wing movements
arguing for censorship arguing for
people to lose their jobs not be
platform this um because they said
something that somebody found offensive
I think actually I don't want anything
to do with that if that's the left right
I don't want that label anymore they you
know I can't bring myself now to simply
say I'm a left winger without a caveat
which says but not in the contemporary
way of understanding the letter this is
something I wanted to ask you about in
terms of running the battle of ideas and
censorship and platform means there is
this idea that giving people a platform
is in a way enabling their views and
therefore if they have bad views or the
wrong views you are therefore
responsible what is your attitude to you
know giving a space for people to talk
from across the spectrum and the critics
that might say well you've you've given
a platform to this person that I
personally disagree with therefore you
are all evil and bad and and whatever
else that comes out of it
I think the golden rule for us is if
it's politically relevant and if it's
interesting then we will look to give it
a platform if it's a debate that we
think needs to happen then it's
something that we you should facilitate
and something that we should get
involved in so that you know Pete
everyone whether you're the editor of a
magazine or the organisation
organizer of a festival you have to look
at what is going to produce a good
debate and a successful debate and one
actually a debate that we're sort of
politically interested in expanding the
conversation so that doesn't mean that
you we've you know just had discussions
about and talked about people being set
up but doesn't mean you find the mad
person who's got the really extreme
views on you know antiabortion or
whatever it is the kind of really really
crazy view and you put them on a
platform then with some very mild person
let them battle it out that's and that's
not no platforming someone by the way
that's just having a sensible view of
how to put on an event or how to have a
discussion but the cold panic about no
platform is a really disingenuous
conversation because actually it's not
about you know it's it never has I've
never looked at a panel that's been
questioned and no platform and I've been
involved in this for many years but we'd
spiked and when I was at university at
the University of Sussex and there was
campaigns around no platforming there
every panel that's been challenged has
to my mind been really quite mild I mean
in terms of whether it's been Julie
bindle or some from the Tory Party it's
always it's never a kind of rabid kind
of viciously murderous person who you
think of why would anyone want to listen
to them it
it's just someone who's a bit
politically contentious and so the fear
about no platforming often just come
from people not wanting to have the
person that they disagree with heard but
once you guess over that you have to say
that a platform what is a platform if
you've got a for example our debates
most of them take place where you've got
sort of five people two or three on each
side and then a chair if you have a
strong chair who can facilitate a public
debate then you really don't have to
worry about what's being said and its
effect on the audience because there's
this type of thing in relation to
platforming that you know this is the
crazy thing about universities and
especially ones at Sussex they would
never have a you kit person on a
platform even though actually at that
time you Kip was doing relatively well
in the polls and it was actually
something interesting to investigate and
what their views were the people at the
University of Sussex and students were
terrified that you kept this new kept
guy was going to get up and say you know
whatever they thought he was going to
say all black people should be deported
and then all the student populace at
Sussex would be like yeah I mean it was
just a complete misunderstanding of both
the power of that speaker and the nature
of the audience so it all comes down to
a distrust of people's ability to
challenge things you know I've been
almost hounded off panels before because
I've spoken about controversial things
at university and I you know the
students have not been swayed by my
point of view the opposite has happened
I think we the problem with the no
platforming panic is it's again I mean
this is a theme it's again it's a
distrust of the public's ability to hold
people to account challenge people and
it's also the case that there's also
this sort of idea that we've just been
talking about labels if you have someone
that's slightly more hardened in their
position that they're somehow an
extremist and what are we supposed to
have beige panels with everyone who's
going to say roughly the same kind of
middling thing I mean who wants to go
and see that it's not it because it you
know you can sanitize debate by
basically saying nobody's saying
anything that is going to obsess anyone
anywhere in the room in which case this
festival will just write no one because
it would just bring you know boring
basically but I I think that we
conference two problems one is the the
way that people are labelled bigots and
we've all made jokes about it here and
you've said you know we're not seasoned
on recipe and it is quite ludicrous but
actually genuinely it's not pleasant
no of course Jeremy and you know
actually you know when people call me a
Nazi or say I'm a fascist neighbor and I
don't just mean using the label I mean
seriously accuse me of enabling fascism
or replicating Enoch pals rivers of
blood speeches these are you know to
your face I mean these are very serious
things to suggest you know it's somebody
responsible for the murderous I mean I
get the idea that I have to explain that
the Holocaust of Jewish people is not
something that I not only agree with but
that I have any remote struck with is
ludicrous but when they say you're
enabling the rise of fascism in this
country a militarized vicious
anti-humanist nihilistic ideology which
I despise and I have to go no I'm not
it sounds pathetic but but if you label
people bigots and we know that there's a
whole new range transphobic Islamophobic
there's all sorts of things which you
can be labeled not because you are a
bigot but because you said something
that goes against what a very narrow
group of people representing that
community but not voted by that
community decided to label as lima
phobic so you will know there many
people who are transgender don't agree
with trans activists millions of people
who are Muslims don't agree with the
people who say on behalf of all Muslims
I call you Islamophobic that's one
problem we would just basically have to
go and check the list of who's somebody
else is called a bigot on the other hand
that's a good way of finding speakers
though all the right things but on the
uran and this is what it's gonna say
with a lot of students I talked to your
kind of newly espousing free speech in
and I like to think that we've at least
opened their minds to it and that we you
know a lot of free speech societies and
have kind of you know somebody would
invite me because every invite read my
book and they're all enthused we're
going to do this and then there
we're gonna invite so-and-so and
actually they're going to invite a
bigger a real bigot because they think
that the way to confront the bands is to
invite somebody for the sake of annoying
everybody at TechShop tactic you know I
know this personal get banned so we're
going to invite X I'm not gonna name
names but there are obviously some
people you know I suppose the archetype
it will be Katie Hopkins or Tommy
Robinson listen we thought we'd invite
them because that will really upset all
of our kind of censorious woke and I
said why would you do that I'm glad
anything interesting to say
and that's the thing is you don't want
to I I think you have an editorial
responsibility as I was indicated to put
together interesting compelling pearls
of people who is seriously going to
discuss the issues in hand and very
often the people who were the most well
known as the outrage mongers are
actually not that interesting now if you
think they are that's that's that's a
legitimate invite them but if you're
going to just invite them to be symbolic
of the fact that you're anti censorship
that's actually as disrespectful to
ideas as those people were no
platforming as well nobody's entitled to
a platform just because they're banned
from everywhere then actually it doesn't
mean that I'm gonna go well it just out
of annoyance I mean yeah there on the
other hand there's there's been times
when you know it's like a feature now of
public debate in which there are first
of all whatever first of all or event
will put on something someone will be
some one will complain about X person
being given a platform and then all the
other speakers will back away and say we
don't want to buy a gilt of Association
be involved in this event because you're
giving a platform to this person for my
appointee to be who I have always
thought say for example like if I manage
to get on a panel with Steve Bannon or
any of these people have caused
controversy I die to do it because the
challenge of the challenge of being able
to get into a space where you could have
the opportunity to politically humiliate
and take down an opponent it's like
that's what you want who wants to if
you're really serious about your
political views which I like to think we
are
you want to win people over you want to
win the argument you don't just want to
keep chatting let's just chat with
people for ever and ever and that's just
you know throw around and if you want to
win the argument so what better
opportunity then to be given someone
who's challenging who you know everyone
is running scared from but then you know
sure I'm not sanic I'm blowing smoke up
my own ass but it's like you know yeah
if you did manage to politically debate
them and win wouldn't that be far better
than everyone backing away and
pretending like this person didn't exist
so there's an element of cowardice in
this discussion there you know that I
think gets missed where a lot of the
time when people say well I'm not
joining a platform with this person
because they're a bigot
you think well if there's such a
disgusting despicable bigot who nobody
agrees with in ensuring you can blow
them over like that just go and do it so
doesn't get anyone's consent we haven't
invited Steve on Newsnight no even you
know I don't think I'd particularly be
that interest in what Steve Owens got to
say now no but they invited Steve Bannon
actually the economists had a festival
invited Steve Bannon they expressly said
they were inviting Steve Bannon to
defeat his arguments and to humiliate
him which you know that was their aim as
I might be disinclined to take that say
yes to the invitation if you've already
proclaimed that with your reign but
nonetheless he said yes and half of the
British and UK and American speakers at
that festival pulled out and Ella and I
didn't and which by the way he weren't
even on a panel anything to do with
think what but there was a real attempt
at bullying the festival to pull him and
in fact the New Yorker actually did pull
they'd also invited him now whatever one
thinks about Steve Bannon if you think
that he I don't think that Steve Bannon
is responsible for every I think he's
over flattered as being responsible for
a range of movements which I think that
in his dreams he wished he was having an
influence over
the idea that he's created all of these
populist movements around Europe we
think no actually we don't need Steve
Bannon
people are kind of quite angry with
things right but nonetheless they say
he's responsible for that in which case
it would seem to me you have a
responsibility to expose his ideas to
interrogation and an argument I actually
think Steve bannon's have rather or an
interesting character and therefore I
don't see the need to have him I
wouldn't not have him out because I
think he's you know that and that's the
way you're trying to try to think of
things I mean we're also by the way a
small organization with no money we
can't afford to fly in everything or
American speaker saying you kind of and
I wanted to just at this point say that
you asked how do you get people I mean a
lot of people say no it was just
speaking at the best of ideas and say
well I'd never true how could you put on
that event you seem to be questioning
you know this and we go yes it's the
interrogating and orthodoxy that's the
idea well how dare you know I'm not
going to do it and people will say I
wouldn't speak in that festival I think
the fact that every year we get 400 plus
speakers across the political range is a
credit to them and I'm delighted that
you you're doing your trigonometry live
at the bad ride is with and Ordonez
because Android Dennis and I are
well-known political opponents of each
other when it comes to the brexit er
here we've come head-to-head on on good
morning Britain and in live debates and
so on and so forth but my god that man
deserves credit because he says of
course I've come along and speaker the
battle of ideas of course I'll go on
trigonometry and I don't just mean
Andrew Dennis there's lots of people
like that we should not be frightened of
having the discussions with each others
if we're really serious about what we
believe as AMA says we should try and
win over audiences of all shapes and
sizes which is why you should be there
the battle of ideas absolutely at what
point does it go from protecting
reputation and verted commerce and tip
into intellectual cowardice with not
wanting to go up against somebody who
you disagree with we don't know the
answer to that I mean I one thing I
would say is I have a case
they said I don't want to go on the
platform I mean if I think somebody is
just not serious it's just gonna come
out with a load of bad I mean I aren't
you've got to decide yourself whether
that's not no problem you just re you
know you have a limited amount of time
in your life I knew that and so on well
I think that that whether its
intellectual cowardice or not
to paraphrase j/s mill you know you
can't really be convincing in your own
argument if you don't test it out
against somebody else's how do you even
know if you believe what you believe
unless you expose it to a range of other
arguments and my fear is that if we
don't really rescue a spirit of debate
in society that people will not be able
to argue anymore
you know that's why so many young people
are so shocked when they hear an
opposite he's like oh oh oh because I've
actually only heard one side of the
argument and I always see what you need
to done is steel yourself in among some
range of debate over arguments you've
never heard before so you can think
actually this is confirmed that I am at
sea right Oh
possibly just possibly you hear
something you think maybe when I was 17
I had very strong opinions on a range of
issues thankfully over the years I've
changed my mind I by the way hope that I
change my mind in the next decade and
I'm not exactly but I mean I have
principles I believe in but the idea
that you would go this is it this is it
I will never think anything other than
this I don't want to hear anything else
I'm never reading a book I'm never being
challenged my goodness intellectual
death awful and I also think we need to
recognize that there needs to be a bit
more of a giving people space and
sympathizing with people I mean that
quite seriously and giving people the
benefit that's out because especially
with young people I can remember when I
was in my late teens early 20s and first
started kind of properly getting
involved in politics
I had my opinions and when people
challenged them it would really upset me
I mean it to the point where I'd you
know my now who's now my husband
used to be a member of the associates
works party and we have the most
ferocious I mean the left all his fights
worst among itself ferocious arguments
where we'd like scream and hit each
other and it would be really terrible
[Laughter]
and then eventually you know when I
starts to do in journalism work and I
get put up against people and it would
it's really hard I mean it is really
hard to learn how to argue and there's
actually this book Claire writes in her
book as well that there is actually an
art to debate and discussion that is
learned and you won't get it immediately
and it is true that if you but start off
believing this is my absolute principle
and often it's when someone comes and
challenges it and you realize that
you're wrong and that's when it hurts
the worst and that's when you will be
most viciously lash out so it's a point
in which we have to give kind of have a
sense that these things will happen
people will make mistakes and so if you
go on a platform with someone or you
debate someone and it ends catastrophic
Lee you do not put a black mark through
their name and that's it forever more
you understand that these things are a
process and it doesn't just happen like
that and I think especially for young
people and all students and universities
or whoever is people who are just being
brought into their kind of political
awakening as it were you've got to allow
a space for them to make mistakes change
and be open to things and part the
problem I think now is that you met you
make one wrong turn or you say one wrong
thing we do one wrong performance and
that's it and awfully human being a much
more complex than that
and if that really was the case and we
were just going to write off people the
minute we disagreed with them on the
minute they said something that we
didn't quite like then there would there
would be no battle of ideas there would
be none of these things because
everything would have just be shut down
like if I got held to account for some
of the things I said when I was 20 it
would be appalling yeah a bit of a kind
of generous spirit towards the way I
think is lacking and needs to be brought
back into it and if I gave you giving
you one final thing because I was on the
program when I when when the book came
out one of the things I slightly regret
is that unintentionally I popularized
the concept of snowflakes because I was
actually just using an American phrase
that was very well widely used to
describe a phenomenon of thin-skinned
easily offended young people and then
it's become as Wikipedia will tell you
they say it's me that brought it in but
you know whatever because I actually now
find that irritating when we will say oh
don't be a snowflake because even though
I probably say a bit but I I know that
can be a lack in generosity right
because I think that we can all we
without sounding that we're going into
therapy I think a degree of political
empathy mean if we sort of say we don't
want over literalism we've got to
understand metaphor I think we've also
got to be able to put ourselves in each
other's shoes and try and understand why
somebody's coming at something from a
different political point of view and I
think that sense of being open-minded
and generous of spirit that doesn't mean
that you have to kind of go oh I don't
want to upset you and I'm now good to
not say anything than much thank you but
it doesn't mean that you write people
off or can't cure them to such an extent
that they can't come back and so I hope
that one of the things that's really
nice I mean I do remember that um just
before the referendum um rather after
the referendum people actually said to
us um oh my god I've never you know
there are people here who voted leave
you know cause we were in the Barbican
in London and that wasn't unusual but
then there was quite a lot of leavers
who said well I've met some really
fantastic I've met some really great
people and some of them voted remain you
know and that's what you yes we're all
citizens I mean we've got to the point
now where we forgotten that we did
things in good faith broadly speaking
well it's a great thing that you do I
think our times up front it's been
fantastic to have you both back on we
will be at the Battle of ideas having a
discussion with Lord of Darkness
we'll also be speaking on different
panels you guys will be speaking on
different panels and no doubt there's
some brilliant things happening for
anyone who wants to come along it's on
the second and the third of November can
we in London off because we have to
yes so this is we will be giving away a
couple of tickets to some of our fans as
we've discussed but also if people want
to go and buy a ticket what's the best
way to do that just head to the website
battle of ideas doubled at UK or check
out our social media princes yes you've
got just under a month now for tickets
and you buy one even for the day or the
weekend
hexina and there's special half-price
tickets for weekend tickets for students
and special concessions I think at
school pupils and come for one day for
free and anyway it's cheaper off the
price snowflake friendly there you go I
never used that word myself either but
we will be there as well so come and say
hello if you're around it's a great
place to be it's a great place to meet
people it's a great place to explore
ideas and we will be back in a week's
time with another brilliant episode see
you next week guys bye bye thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pot and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word
[Music]